another thing to talk about last night
is uh teslas
everyone that gets a tesla uh thinks
they're part of the development team at
spacex
i've never seen a product like this
where you buy the product and you become
also a spokesman for the product
it's not enough that you own a tesla
everyone around you needs to know about
the tesla
what it can do what elon musk is up to
what the starlink satellite system is to
it's a [ __ ]
car yes it's electric maybe it's the
future but who gives the [ __ ]
why are you going and ruining my night
never shutting up all the cyber trucks
coming out and you know what that no one
no
shut up it's a 37 000
car okay a public school teacher could
afford it
it's not impressive it is what it is
it's just a [ __ ] car
i get it you drive an iphone around it's
it's got all the bells and whistles it's
it's you know it's self-driving it's so
i like driving
all these idiots are like well you don't
even have to drive you're gonna stood in
your car
and what are you doing what are you
doing
working on a hedge fund drive you have
nothing else to do
well you could self-drive yeah we know
why you drunk
we know what you want to do you drug
addict yeah you could self-drive so you
could cut lines of coke on a [ __ ] cd
case or whatever
or whatever you have yeah that's you
know that's a reference from a long time
ago but
i bet those people still have those
[ __ ] i used to do it on a gym blossom
cd
but that's my point i don't have
problems with tesla owners but everybody
thinks that they start talking about
elon musk and they start talking about
the stock fright
the stock price you think i ever bought
a car and i'm like well
ford is actually up because of you're
not
part of that you own a car
you're not part of the thing
it's really frustrating
when people with teslas don't understand
that you're just buying a [ __ ] car
this it's a weird cult that you need to
convert everybody else into
everybody needs to know how cool teslas
are like what you know so as somebody i
know
has when they just look at me they're
like they're the future like very
seriously
they're the future it's like hey why
don't you shut up
about the future okay it's a cool
electric car
other companies will come out with cars
that compete with tesla jags doing it
ford's doing it a lot of people will do
it
teslas will still probably be always
maybe the coolest or not
i don't know but elon musk is a little
annoying and i'm sick of them doing his
starling satellites i don't even know
what the [ __ ] they do
but they make me think it's a ufo i
think the planet's being invaded and
we're all going to get colonized and
raped and i get so excited
and then when i find out it's just this
[ __ ] goofing off
i get upset so if you own a tesla
congrats but please just pipe down it
becomes like the covet thing you're like
you don't understand yeah i i
i unders no i know it's no the
car drives it set you put on self
driving it drives itself and
soon in a year it'll have full
self-driving
why even get in the car why doesn't the
car just go to
[ __ ] ralph's for you why doesn't the
car [ __ ] your wife
why do you have to even be in the car
why doesn't the car go to the meeting
and say the [ __ ] things you're going
to say well
it drives itself i just sit in it i'm
just a passenger
okay we got it we understand that it's
fascinating
and great and and and i'm happy about
everyone that owns a tesla i'm very
happy about it and i'm not
[ __ ] on them i have a nice car don't
talk about it because it's boring
no one cares about cars i don't care
about cars
i have a nice car it's a decent car it's
a fine car there's better cars than mine
there's cooler cars than mine it is what
it is
it's not a big deal okay my car is also
not mine's a gas guzzling truck
so it's not cool i don't get to talk
about the charger
talking about the tesla charger all the
time and where's the well there's gonna
they're actually could have supercharged
stations or if you pull up your chargers
i hope you start getting shot in the
head at the supercharged
tesla station why don't we start doing
that why don't people start shooting
people in the head
and taking their money outside the
supercharge just an idea
wink free idea i'm just a little sick of
it i'm not i'm not hating on the tesla
people
i was in rogan's test it's very cool it
goes very fast well the ludicrous mode
is very fast i understand that but where
are you going
where are you going you don't have
anywhere to go you're going
fast to what what exactly are you doing
are you in a chase are you using that
car
to chase down a man who has just thrown
a girl into a van
is that why you need ludicrous mode so
you can go so fast
and then find that van and then [ __ ]
beat that guy up and then free that girl
is that what you're doing or are you
going to
like i don't know [ __ ] dairy queen
you know i mean it's like enough for any
i'm just a little sick do you understand
my frustration with these people of
course
it's a weird brainwashed cult of people
well but it's people that just want to
talk about
you you have a tesla you want to talk
about that yeah yeah you have a tesla
and all you talk about is your tesla
that's not true but that's not i wasn't
really going at you i was going to a lot
of people because he has a tesla yeah
that's a weird call to people giannis
has one michael has one yeah yeah
my friend michael has they just they
just they go you never you'll never go
back
what does that mean i'm already looking
at the lucid air it's a better ev it's
coming out in like two years you know
there's others here's the thing you'll
never go back you'll you'll go
back this is this whole thing is like
you'll go back it's like
yo you go black you never go back it's
like maybe that's the case but
with tesla i i mean let's stop acting
like you've done some people that have a
tesla act like they've really done
something
they act like they've really done like
they've accomplished something now
you've accomplished something because
you used to be too drunk to even get in
a car
and now you've been sober and you're
doing all this that's great but it's
like i have a range rover who cares
right it doesn't matter i don't talk
about it because it's not interesting
the the [ __ ] british monsters that
own range rover not trying to help the
world
by the way they like the car burns a lot
of gas
and we locked to sell it to rappers we
locked the seller to house wolves
and rappers that's who drives range
rovers housewives and rappers and i'm
half of each
and and that's who drives it but enough
with the the tesla [ __ ] like enough with
it i mean i
you you you're starting to get better
about it but you love
the beginning i was a little annoying
about it well you just love talking to
people about it yeah
you know and it's like there's other
things you're a fascinating guy there's
other things
that you can talk about besides your car
your golf your tesla yeah whatever
but it's just you know yeah see what i
do when i walk in a room
i i always give people sort of a
dissertation
and i i don't say like oh the cool thing
about the is that the sunroof
i don't do that i tell peop when i walk
in a room
i i tell people why they are
why they are where they are in life and
that's what i feel is nice
and i feel like it's the ultimate act of
charity to walk in a room and
look at someone and identify their
weakness and magnify it in front of
[Laughter]
others